[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport à
l'émission est toujours consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est parti pour le sommaire football
ont joué ce dimanche les demi finales de
la coupe des yvelines et plaisir n'a pas
réussi à se qualifier pour la finale
les plaisirs oies se sont inclinés 2 à 0
face à carey a grésillons plus
d'informations à suivre golf à un grand
salon baptisé le mondial du golf va
s'ouvrir ce vendredi à mantes la jolie
plus de 150 exposants dont la fédération
française seront présents pour avoir
plus de détails sur cet événement nous
recevrons le commissaire général
charles-henri bacheliers course à pied
la 25e édition de la gurp course s'est
déroulée ce week-end plus de 350
sportifs ont participé cette année ce 10
km tous les détails dans quelques
instants
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence par du football la coupe du
monde féminine commence le 7 juin
prochain et les immigrants participer à
cette grande fête
la fifa et le comité d'organisation ont
retenu croissy-sur-seine comme terrain
d'entraînement pour quatre équipes
nationales l'équipe de france l'afrique
du sud les causes c'est la dream team
américaine vont s'entraîner sur le site
à partir du 3 juin
les équipements avait déjà été utilisé
par l'équipe de russie pendant l'euro
2016 on écoute le maire de la commune au
micro de tv 78 c'est une surprise non
c'est la continuation de ce qu'on avait
déjà engagé avec l'euro 2016 et puis
l'équipe d'angleterre l'année d'après
qui est venu s'entraîner ici
donc effectivement on avait candidaté
pour la coupe du monde l'équipe de
france et premier numéro un mondial
l'équipe des états unis où il aborde de
convenir bien sûr escale intéressant
c'est qu'il aura des entraînements
ouverts
donc on pourra faire profiter nos jeunes
sportifs ils pourront côtoyer des
sportifs de haut niveau et ça c'est
aussi très important pour moi
la 8e édition de la coupe du monde
féminine se déroulera du 7 juin au 7
juillet dans l'hexagone des animations
seront organisées dans la ville de
croissy sur seine avec notamment la mise
en place d'une fan zone derrière le
terrain d'entraînement direction plaisir
à présent le fo plaisir war recevez
carrière grésillons demi-finale de la
coupe des yvelines dans une partie assez
équilibrée ce sont finalement les
visiteurs qui repartent avec la victoire
des images d'aurélie ronde un montage de
jules grandes villes
match à enjeu à plaisir le club local
recevait carrière grésillons demi-finale
de la coupe des yvelines après une
première période rythmée ce sont
finalement les visiteurs qui ouvrent le
score sur un pénalty 1 à 0 ce sera le
score à la mi temps c'est une première
paraît pas très disputé forcément une
demi-finale tout le monde a envie de
jouer la finale ça assez équilibré on
voit que carrère c'est une équipe solide
et qui auront aussi à ouvrir le score
sur un penalty un peu un coup du sort on
sait le jeu on a toujours espoir
il ya de la place pour aller gagner ce
match on a deux équipes de la même
division et on se connaît on est capable
d'aller les battre
malgré une domination plaisir oise en
seconde période les joueurs n'arrivent
pas à conclure et concède un second
penalty sur cette action
les joueurs ne reviendront pas dans la
partie score final 2 à 0 très déçu très
déçu après c'est le football hand on va
commencer par féliciter carrière nokia
qui a mérité sa qualification qu'en se
qualifiant le mérite donc bravo à eux
d'abord on a mis les ingrédients pour
gagner ce match on a quarante cinq
premières minutes qui était à peu près
équilibrées on prend un premier but sur
un petit détail presse on reste quand
même dans le match je trouve que la
deuxième mi temps on a totalement dominé
l'adversaire a touché la barre le
gardien aussi il était sur quelques
points on n'a vraiment pas eu de chance
pour plaisir il faudrait espérer un peu
plus de chance l'année prochaine pour
soulever la coupe de son côté carrière
grésillons rencontrera le club de vélizy
en finale de la coupe des yvelines le 16
juin à verneuil sur seine
football toujours en nationale 3 verset
s'est largement imposé sur le terrain de
le mée ce week-end score final 3 buts à
0 un résultat à l'extérieur qui permet
aux hommes de la cité royale d'intégrer
le top 5
il pointe désormais à la 5e place à
quatre points du podium de ce
championnat
une information insolite à présent la
fédération française de football
envisage de vendre un centre
d'entraînement semblable à
clairefontaine à la chine
le site construit dans le sud des
yvelines est mondialement connue pour
abriter les équipes de foot france de
football avec toutes les technologies
derrier dernière génération pour les
sportifs le président de la fff noël le
graet voudrait vendre le savoir faire de
ce site pour une implantation aux
alentours de pékin si le deal se fait ce
serait une grande première mondiale
après une large page football un mot de
baseball à présent mauvaise opération
pour les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux les signé mon teint se sont
inclinés deux fois ce week-end contre
les templiers de sénart ils ont perdu la
première partie 8 à 6 et le second match
5 à 2 au classement montigny le
bretonneux descend la troisième place de
la poule b prochain match dimanche
prochain à domicile contre metz st on
ouvre maintenant une page golf 1 mondial
est organisé de ce vendredi 12 jusqu'au
cas dimanche 14 avril à mantes la jolie
dans le parc des expositions de l'île
l'aumône
je ne vous parle pas d'une compétition
mais d'un grand salon où 150 exposants
seront présents pour nous parler de cet
événement nous recevons sur ce plateau
le commissaire général charles-henri
bacheliers bonsoir bonsoir
alors qu'est ce que c'est concrètement
ce salon alors un événement sur le golf
tel qu'on peut rencontrer dans d'autres
activités par exemple salon de
l'agriculture où le salon de la chasse
toute la famille afin de sauvages
killing de se fermer ses portes il ya
quelques jours
en gros on va retrouver tout ce qui fait
le la culture golfique va retrouver du
faiseur de clubs du parcours de golf les
gens qui organisent le voyage de golf
que des choses comme ça un petit peu
d'art de vivre
en gros on va essayer d'en faire et
c'est l'ambition de mon groupe de faire
du mondial du golf
un magasin de jouets géants pour sale
gosse golfeur on y trouve tout voilà
pourquoi on l'appelle mondiale c'est
pourquoi parce que il y avait un salon
qui a existé qui s'appelait le salon du
golf qui était en perte forte de vitesse
où plus grand monde voulait aller donc
le nom été galvaudé j'ai d'ailleurs
acheté cette société au mois de novembre
pour faire disparaître le nom et qu'on
n'en parle plus le psy parce que le
concept était tellement différent de ce
qui se passait dans feue salon du golf
que savait plus rien à voir donc prendre
le même nom c'est un salon sur le golf
on peut dire un salon du golf mais son
nom est le mondial du golf
voilà parce que les grandes dimensions
c'est qu'on joue on va taper en
extérieur dans les salons traditionnels
on est en indoor est donc comptable dans
des filets et votre banque vous avez le
contact club balle un bon bruit ou pas
est-ce que vous êtes fait mal aux mains
ou pas est-ce que vous êtes fait
engueuler par le fit heures ou pas parce
que vous n'avez pas bien fait mais vous
voyez pas voler la balle
or nous ce qu'on aime bien les golfeurs
on sait que quand on fait un mauvais
coup qui est efficace on appelle ça un
coup commercial mais ça fait pas très
plaisir la carte avance mais pas le jeu
comme on aimerait ce qu'on aime c'est
voir la balle volait biens volés avoir
un contact est un plaisir jusqu'au bout
là il y aura deux practice un practice
de wedding petit jeu pour faire approche
et bunkers et un practice de frappe ou
ceux qui font plus de 270 mètres les
mettrons dans la seine si je comprends
bien ce sera plus divertissant que
l'ancien salon alors le but c'est que ça
ressemble au golf pourquoi est-ce que ce
site de l'îlot moon est absolument
génial c'est qu'il est d'abord
magnifique voilà donc gré des sites
magnifiques 1 à flins dans les yvelines
même en ile-de-france et en france après
il faut qu'ils soient capables
d'accueillir des événements de masse
dire qu'on est des accès qui soit qui
permette que la logistique se passe bien
parce que sinon ça devient très vite un
enfer quand vous accueillez deux trois
mille personnes
quatre mille personnes sur une journée
qui viennent tous en une heure au même
endroit plus 1000 exposants
si ça ne fait pas en termes de parking
d'accès si c'est pas fluide c'est le but
que ce soit avantageux lui du coup alors
c'était logique parce que j organise
déjà d'autres salons qu'on a déjà une
structure énorme qu installer un énorme
barnum qui fait la taille d'un terrain
de foot voilà couvert avec un plancher
chauffant quelque chose imaginez une
tante presque - de luxe pour un mariage
ont construit la même sauf qu'au lieu de
faire 200 m² elle fait 6500 mètres
carrés et pourquoi les yvelines c'est
parce qu'il y a eu la ryder cup 2018 qui
a été organisée ici alors au golf mais
semaine 50 en nubie alors il ya la rue
dante où il ya l'implantation de d'un
autre événement qu'on organise le salon
la chasse afin de sauvages qui a lieu
déjà à mantes-la-jolie sur l'île aux
mômes qui a fermé ses portes ya une
semaine
donc ça c'est une des raisons mais aussi
parce que les yvelines tout le monde ne
sait pas mais c'est le premier
département golfique de france voilà il
y à 26 18 trous dans le département il y
a trente mille licenciés et en france
les 410 mille licenciés donc si on était
aussi nombreux dans chaque département
de france comme dans les yvelines
on serait 3 millions de golfeurs en
france or on est 80 x mois donc il ya
énormément de gaulle faire dans les
yvelines par exemple à moins de 30
minutes du site vous avez 20 18 trous
voilà donc les gens pourront aussi
combiner la possibilité de venir
découvrir tout ce que fait l'industrie
toutes les nouveautés les grands
classiques trouve un nouveau putter
nouvelle série un nouveau drive se faire
un footing trouver des chaussures un sac
des vêtements prévoir un voyage et dans
la demi journée ou le lendemain aller
jouer dans un des magnifiques parcours
que notre beau département propose et la
ryder cup n'a pas joué dans
l'organisation d'un tel événement alors
la ryder cup évidemment était un
moteur pour le golf en terme d'image en
termes d'adhésion il ya des énormément
d'étrangers qui sont venus découvrir le
golf en ile-de-france et dans les
yvelines
ça permet aussi à beaucoup de golfeurs
d'autres régions et départements de
venir assister à la ryder est de coupler
pour jour le plus célèbre d'entre eux
c'était un étranger et michael jordan
qui est qui a écumé cinq ou six golf de
la région dont certains des yvelines qui
n'a pas arrêté je faisais il faisait 2
parcours par jour la fin il à la fin des
terres et donc il ya évidemment il ya
cet effet d'entraînement il ya le coach
national qui est juste à côté d'ici qui
fait qu aussi pour cette raison là il ya
un effet boule de neige en s'échouant
bien sûr s'il ya une toute logique en
plus c'est entre paris et la normandie
où il ya une grosse zone de pratique où
beaucoup de pratiquants vont pas de
pratiquer le week-end où habitent les
week-ends ou dans les yvelines
donc voilà termes d'accès de culture
d'emplacements ça faisait sens de le
faire là vous avez vous attendez combien
de personnes sur cette alliance mille
15000 personnes
ouais c'est beaucoup c'est vraiment
beaucoup mais par rapport à ce que nous
annonce la billetterie en ligne au degré
yens il faut être expert forcément en
golf pour venir alors pas du tout
justement
le but aussi d'un événement comme
celui-ci c'est pouvoir rendre accessible
un univers et
c'est le cas du mondial du golf qui rend
accessibles de parce qu'on propose
et pas de ce que l'on pourrait proposer
beaucoup d'exposants le rendre
accessible par exemple les premiers
d'entre eux partenaires la fédération
française de golf réinstalle dans le
cadre du mondial c'est village découvert
qu'ils avaient installées partout en
france en faisant un tour du village
ryder cup pour permettre la découverte
des du golfe
oh non golfeurs au ceux qui veulent
juste découvrir se renseigner tous a
donc des mises au jeu très facile
d'ailleurs vendredi je crois qu'on a
déjà 300 à 350 scolaires qui sont
inscrits pour venir spontanément avec
des classes des écoles des sorties qui
vont convenir là dessus nous on a fait
ça gratuit pour les moins de 18 ans
c'est aussi pour permettre aux logements
et aux familles qui voudraient juste
venir découvrir et aux jeunes qui
voudraient peut-être avoir l'idée de
découvrir ce magnifique sport et ce jeu
absolument envoûtant de passer la porte
et devenir au mondial il ya aussi des
exposants comme google qui va proposer
par exemple un trou en un pour les non
golfeurs se sera va vérifier par rapport
à la licence est animé de nom et prénom
ils avaient allumé road licence et pour
ce tronc en est réservé aux non golfeurs
il ya une voiture à gagner
enfin pas totalement désagréable ça vaut
le coup de venir taper une balle et
tenter sa chance il ya plus de chances
de gagner colotto la question si on veut
venir à ce salon il reste encore des
places
évidemment une perse mille personnes qui
sont attendues me reste des places où il
ya toujours des places une billetterie
en ligne sur le site du mondial du golf
mondial du golf point com ou alors c'est
utilisable sur place au guichet avec de
sympathiques de thèse qui font des cons
sourire merci à vous battre sur ce
plateau vous souhaite bon courage pour
l'organisation dans la dernière ligne
droite de cet événement merci nous
augmentons reçu et je le rappelle le
mondial du golf
comment seront dix à mantes la jolie et
se terminera à dimanche prochain après
le golf du basket dans le championnat de
nationale 3 trappe s'est incliné ce
samedi à l'extérieur quand brees sur le
réveil sur le score de 87 à 4 ans 3 les
trappistes reste donc à la deuxième
place du championnat à une journée de la
fin de la saison et ne monteront donc
pas en nationale 2 derniers matchs à
domicile contre nantes samedi soir
prochain toujours en basket chez les
féminines le chesnay-versailles engrange
une 19e victoire cette saison les filles
devimco berdych se sont imposés
104 à 58 à l'extérieur sur le teint de
gravenchonnais le cv 60,18 reste donc
premier de sa poule et attend désormais
les pay off de fin de saison pour savoir
si oui ou non l'équipe montera en
nationale 2 furent on ouvre maintenant
une page handball dans le championnat de
nationale 2 féminine à montigny le
bretonneux n'y arrive pas lésiné
montaigne se sont inclinés à domicile
contre plouvorn score final 26 à 20 une
défaite qui n'arrange pas les
saint-quentinoises qui vise une place
dans le top 5 pour cette fin de saison
elles sont pour l'instant septième du
classement enfin toujours en bas
l'équipe masculine de plaisir a failli
remporter sa sixième victoire de la
saison les hommes de victor garrigues et
n'ont pu faire mieux qu'une égalité face
à strasbourg ce week end le score 28
partout équipes restent premiers
relégables il devra engranger les des
points le 27 avril prochain sur le
terrain de bois colombes on prend
maintenant la direction de
voisins-le-bretonneux un championnat de
france de billard était organisée ce
week-end dans la salle du club local le
billard-club vie s'y noient au total
seize participants venus de seize
régions de l'hexagone se sont affrontés
pendant trois jours sont les règles du
billard français
on pouvait notamment voir à l'oeuvre
pierre billes et pratiquant voisins le
bretonneux depuis 20 ans une grande joie
pour le président du club
la fédération a accepté notre
proposition et nous a fait confiance et
on en a été particulièrement honoré
ce que bon là ainsi que la ville de
voisins et puis quelque part aussi un
petit peu sur saint quentin en yvelines
ça paie c'est pas le niveau 2 c'est pas
le niveau de la ryder cup
mais bon c c'est quand même une finale
de championnat de france
pierre biffi du club de voisins bretons
n'a finalement terminé à la troisième
place le vainqueur et xavier guérin 2 à
draveil
en rugby très belle opération pour
plaisir les plaisirs oise se sont
imposés contre arras lors de la 21e
journée du championnat de fédérale 2 sur
le score de 59 à 26 une bouffée
d'oxygène pour le club
grâce à cette victoire les illinois
remonte à la 9e place du classement
on ouvre une page course à pied la 25e
édition de la glu en course était
organisée ce dimanche matin plus de 350
sportifs se sont inscrits cette année
pour la compétition pour ce 10 km des
images d'aurélie rond à montage de et
xavier gens dimanche 7 avril lui en
cours certains se sont levés très tôt
pour participer à la 25e édition de la
bu en course au départ du gymnase des
droits de l'homme une course à pied de
10 km pour l'occasion certains se sont
fixé des objectifs
j'essaie dans la mesure du possible et
d'essayer d'accrocher un podium mais
avec l'âge
malheureusement sa vie est de plus en
plus difficile donc je crois plus pour
mon plaisir maintenant d'autres au
contraire sont moins ambitieux en tout
cinquante minutes et sera bien un
programme anti c'est bien on tue tant
pis pour cette édition 2010 9 la course
qu'au sens près de 350 inscrits hommes
et femmes
je pense que les gens aiment bien ce
côté nature au bord de l'eau en se
mettant un petit challenge depuis 25 ans
et le challenge de un petit peu de
l'année pour pas mal de gens c'est
j'aime et dix kilomètres à faire donc je
m'entraîne pour faire cette course qui
est proche de chez moi c'est beaucoup de
gens qui sont vraiment la vie nouvelle
qui viennent courir la course a
finalement été remportée par pierre
étienne charbonnel le sportif a bouclé
les 10 km en 38 minutes 40 secondes pour
sa première participation
le deuxième est juste à queue devait pas
très loin on a fait dix bornes ensemble
puis je vais un peu décrochés sur le
sur le dernier kilomètre mais c'est très
bien chez les féminines c'est l'argument
pour toi audrey soulabaille qui remporte
la compétition avec un temps de 43
minutes et 57 secondes s'est contenté
d'être la première voilà même si ce
n'était pas forcément un objectif
c'était juste prendre du plaisir
pas vraiment d'objectif juste la
terminer ce qu'est une petite côtelettes
à mi parcours classé qui emplit un peu
casse pattes
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
26e édition les organisateurs pourrait
modifier légèrement le parcours est
intégrée de la marche nordique au
programme de l'événement
on passe maintenant notre page agenda on
continue à parler de course à pied dans
cet agenda la deuxième édition du
semi-marathon de trappes est programmée
ce dimanche 14 avril au départ du stade
chant sac pour nous parler de ce rendez
vous nous recevons sur ce plateau à lire
ab adjoint au maire de trappes chargé
des sports et aïcha tous au président de
l'association running for africa
partenaire de l'événement bonsoir alors
pourquoi avez vous décidé de renouveler
l'expérience à l'érable et m'a d'abord
parce que la première édition a été une
réussite
on a déjà pu enregistré l'année dernière
pour la première édition plus de 320
inscrits pour le 10 km et le
semi-marathon cette année on a déjà
dépassé les inscrits l'année dernière on
est à près de 400 à l'heure où je vous
parle on espère pouvoir faire courir
plus de 500 personnes vous dimanche
prochain sur la ville de trappes c'était
vraiment une réussite l'année dernière
c'était une formidable réussite on a pu
mobiliser autour de nous le secteur
associatif de la ville aussi bien
évidemment l'association l'entente
athlétique de saint quentin en yvelines
mais aussi des associations caritatives
humanitaires qui travaillent dans le
champ de la solidarité internationale
running for africa en est un exemple et
on a pu mobiliser aussi bien les enfants
qui sont venus courir sur les courses
d'un point 5 km que les seniors les
vétérans même qui courait pour certains
le 10 km et même le semi marathon
justement il y aura une course où vous
disais de 10 km est également des
courses pour les jeunes pourquoi pour
vraiment créer une alchimie sur cette
course
on a vraiment voulu imaginer l'événement
non pas comme une énième compétition
sportive mais comme un événement
familial
le but c'est qu'on puisse venir courir
enfants parents et grands parents
chacun à son rythme chacun selon ses
capacités physiques et donc pour ceux
qui sont les plus aguerris ou 21 km qui
ont l'habitude de faire les courses du
bassin de saint quentin en yvelines
ils pourront courir sur la base de
loisirs est sûre
ville de trappes sur la commune de
trappes découvrir d'ailleurs les
nouveaux quartiers de la commune de
trappes mais également pour les sportifs
du dimanche comme moi recourir le 10 km
et pour les enfants leur donner le goût
de la compétition une plongée soit le
semi marathon
je suis pas encore prêt j'ai eu par
ailleurs un petit pépin physique qui m'a
empêché de m'entraîner comme je
souhaitais mais pour l'instant j'en
reste aux 10 km et j'espère dans les
années qui viennent et de près celui mal
à chatou sous quel est votre rôle vous
je m'appelle donc à cetto sont donc je
suis présidente de l'association running
for africa qui est implanté sur la ville
de trappes depuis un peu plus de deux
ans et effectivement comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure
l'année dernière on a participé à cet
événement avec engouement puisque nous
mêmes de cette souhaitions aussi mettre
en place ce type d'organisation donc ça
tombe bien la ville à anticiper donc
parfait donc on a travaillé en étroite
collaboration avec le service des sports
que je remercie d'ailleurs
et nous avons mis
on pas disposition mais en tous les cas
nous avons donné des ressources humaines
pour vraiment palier et encadrer ce type
d'action qui est très lourd très très
bon donc on a pu mobiliser 24 bénévoles
chez nous cette année on réitère aussi
puisque on espère réitérer même chaque
année pour la réussite de cet événement
mais qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à
renouveler l'expérience s'était bien
passé une dernière on voit là ça s'est
super bien passé l'année dernière donc
nous on a participé du début jusqu'à la
fin au niveau de l'organisation donc
tant sur la remise des t-shirts d'aider
des sacs à dos pour les coureurs sur les
qu'on appelle ça m'a encouragé les
coureurs voilà nos besoins et nous avons
aussi également pu y mettre un stand
pour avoir une visibilité sur notre
association puisque à ce moment là ces
périodes là nous avions un projet de
chantier de solidarité internationale
que l'adjoint au maire d'ailleurs à
aller baali rabais nous soutient et nous
a soutenus jusqu'au bout
donc ça c'est un événement aussi pour
nous où on allie en tous les cas le
sport à des projets de solidarité
internationale ali rabais quand on
entend le discours d'hachette assault on
voit si une énorme organisation derrière
un événement oui forcément là d'un
événement d'un semi-marathon qui a l'air
banal finalement mais qui devient gros
événement en terme d'organisation
oui on s'y prend plusieurs mois al
avance il ya des aspects de sécurité
évidemment assuré il ya les aspects liés
à la compétition puisque il y a un
classement il y à un chronométrage à
réaliser ont travaillé sur tout cela
avec le club
et puis également on a décidé de faire
circuler ce semi-marathon pas uniquement
sur l'île de loisirs on a la chance à
trappes d'avoir les loisirs sur notre
territoire mais également en ville donc
ça veut dire qu'il faut barrer des rues
assurer la sécurité avoir des signaleurs
qui laisse plus ou moins passer les
véhicules quand les coureurs ne sont pas
sur le parcours ont tout ça demande
énormément de ressources humaines au
delà de notre personnel municipal qui
est mobilisée pour l'occasion
on a souhaité l'ouvrir beaucoup aux
habitants de trappes on a la chance on
est une ville de 30 mille habitants je
le dis souvent qui regorge
énergie de bonne volonté et quand on
fait un appel à volontaires on a
énormément de personnes qui se
présentent vraiment j'aurais aimé venir
ici et que tous les bénévoles
ça aurait très grands studios on ad on a
vraiment des personnes de 80 ans des
personnes âgées qui viennent qui
participent à la remise des maillots
qu'ils sont on a des jeunes gens de 16
17 ans qui viennent nous encourager sur
le parcours qui font le ravitaillement
etc et on y voit la diversité la
richesse trappistes au delà de
l'organisation d'un événement sportif
encore une fois c'est une fête de la
ville de trappes une fête familiale où
chacun peut trouver sa place les
sportifs comme les non sportifs running
for africa aide le mâle semi-marathon en
faisant des dons en faisant du bénévolat
alors oui c'est essentiellement du
bénévolat donc nous on intervient
effectivement dans des dans le continent
africain
sur plusieurs thématiques ça peut être
de l'éducation jusqu'à la santé sur des
petits micros projets mais l'objectif en
fait c'est vraiment de de faire
participer la jeunesse les impliqué sur
tous les événements de la ville
et une course comme celle ci la chance
que nous avons c'est que c'est
intergénérationnel et c'est ça qui fait
la richesse en fait de cette course
on discute beaucoup on a on a pu les
jeunes ont pu eux mêmes
parler de leurs propres projets puisque
c'est eux qui portent le projet de
chantier de solidarité internationale et
ça les valorise donc on a besoin d'avoir
des événements comme celui ci sur la
ville de trappes parce qu on regorge
comme nous le disait tout à l'heure même
vivier et un engouement en tous les cas
sur toutes les activités de la ville
sportifs ludiques ou culturelles
cette fois ci c'est sportif mais on est
là alors on va revenir sur le parcours
80% du parcours en pleine nature 20% sur
le bitume
pourquoi mais parce que c'est une
demande oui c'est un souhait de la ville
souvent on se fait une image caricature
et caricaturale de la ville de trappes
on imagine que ce sont des blocs de
béton très anciens c'est une ville où on
n'est pas en sécurité alors que la
réalité très différente quand on y vit
très différent de ce que parfois l'image
médiatique peut en donner
donc on a décidé la course de trappes
réuni de nombreux trappistes mais elle
est évidemment ouverte à tous ceux qui
habitent autour de trappes même bien au
delà donc beaucoup de coureurs viennent
parfois de loin et découvrent ce qu'est
le vrai trappe notamment le nouveau
trappe
les nouveaux bâtiments qui sortent de
terre les quartiers qui seront rénovés
donc en faisant circuler cette course
sur 20% du parcours sur le périmètre de
la ville de trappes
on permet de briser un peu les clichés
les idées reçues sur notre commune et
ont profité à la fois du parcours urbain
dans un cadre relativement agréable et
puis surtout de cette formidable il de
loisirs qui nous permet de courir entre
les arbres sur les sentiers et c'est un
vrai bonheur
il faut avoir un bon niveau pour
participer tout dépend à quelle course
vous vous inscrivez le tout c'est
d'arriver vous donc pour moi par exemple
qui fait le 10 km les nanars je les fais
en 57 minutes ce qui était une fierté je
les fais en moins d'une heure et je
n'avais quasiment aucun entraînement
j'ai commencé à me préparer
même pas un mois avant l'échéance tombe
où et n'importe qui peut venir courir au
moins 10 km pour le semi marathon c'est
quand même autre chose il faut avoir un
vrai entraînement puis après pour les
enfants encore une fois on est sûr de
l'initiation à km 5
on aura des collégiens cette année qui
vont également venir courir en relais
sur le 10 km chacun fera un bout du 10
km et on aura des équipes qui vont se
relayer
encore une fois on veut pouvoir
accueillir tout le monde et donner le
goût de l'athlétisme à chacun aussi mais
à la question est ce qu'il y aura un
jour un marathon à trappes
là on en est au semi-marathon vous
m'aviez parlé l'année dernière d'un
possible marathon dans le futur est-ce
qu'il y en aura
rapidement je rêve où le je pense qu'on
fera tôt ou tard on va monter en
crescendo en puissance et on atterrira
sur le marathon et vous n'êtes pas le
seul à me demander de très nombreux
trappistes sur les sites merci d'être
venu sur ce plateau le semi-marathon de
trappes c'est ce dimanche 14 avril à
partir de 9 heures au programme
également ce week-end du football avec
le championnat de d1 de district
guyancourt reçoit s'est retrouvée ce
dimanche ce sera le choc de cette 19e
journée entre le 3e et le 4e deux
équipes qui comptent le même nombre de
points et qui vise une place sur le
podium en fin de saison si vous voulez
assister à la rencontre le match est
programmé à 15h au stade maurice
bakchich il y aura également du football
mais cette fois-ci américain si vous
passez la région du côté ce week-end du
côté de tours n'hésitez pas à aller voir
le match des templiers d'elancourt
contre les pionniers de touraine et deux
équipes sont au coude à coude pour la
première place de la poule b de deuxième
division le match s'annonce
spectaculaire il aura lieu ce dimanche
on termine par un rendez-vous le
lancement a été fait jeudi dernier à
paris véronique chaplin et son équipe
ont présenté à cette occasion
la 27e édition du type break le concept
le rendez-vous sera organisé le 21 mai
prochain au golf le de la
queue-lez-yvelines et proposera à la
fois des ateliers pour les enfants une
compétition de golf avec des stars la
soirée se terminera par une vente aux
enchères afin de récolter des fonds en
faveur de l'association sos gazelle on
écoute l'organisatrice véronique chaplin
une cinquantaine de champion attendu et
cette année un focus sur les jeunes
ce qu'on va avoir 7 ou 8 ateliers
différents et tous les champions qui
joue au golf ont vraiment insisté pour
cette année paraître part entière sur
les olympiades et les ateliers donc
turon golf le matin et ce qui fait que
l'après midi je pense qu'il aura une
sacrée ambiance entre les champions
encadrant les jeunes des yvelines et
tous les golfeurs qui vont mieux c'est
la fin de cette émission merci d'avoir
suivi très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]